Hey, mom.
Good afternoon, Marissa.
Do you have a minute?
I'm here to assist you however I can.
So, I'm seeing this guy and things are going really well,...
...and then I texted him last night and he never wrote back.
Should I text him again?
Shall I text him for you?
No. No, that would be totally weird.
He mentioned something about a concert Friday night,...
...but he hasn't actually invited me yet.
Do you think I should make other plans?
Let me check your calendar.
At noon on Friday, you have a gynecologist appointment.
Yeah, I know.
The concert's at night.
I've been dying to see Florence and the Machine again.
They were so good last year.
Okay, your washing machine is dying.
The closest Sears Appliance Center is 0.5 miles away.
What? Mom, why don't you ever listen to me?
I'm really sorry about this, but I can't answer your question right now.
I'm just having a bad day and you're not helping.
I don't know what you mean by, "I'm having a bad day."
Would you like me to search the web?
Search the web for what?
I found 9,544,110,700 entries for "what."